[Music]
School M my name is and I'll be your
host today so without further Ado let's
dive into today's episode and to
mark on a great journey together
get ready to be engaged entertained and
inspired today's topic will be about the
mental health in high school you may say
why do we need to know about the mental
health what does High School have to do
with the mental health why is this even
important what can cause mental
disorders what helps in recovering from
a mental
illness well mental health is is a very
important topic and now you'll learn
why as Bley and Bley in 1998 said
depression May refer to a range of
symptoms and adolesence from transient
depressed mood to a Ser clinical
disorder including thoughts of death or
suicide requiring psychiatric
hospitalization therefore te Mental
Health is a crucial issue that needs
attention high school can be a
challenging time for many teams as they
navigate academic pressures social
dynamics and the transition to
adulthood these factors can contribute
to increased stress depression anxiety
and other mental health
issues one key aspect of supporting team
mental health is creating safe and
inclusive
environment schools play a vital role in
this by offering resources like
counseling
services and mental health
programs these resources can provide
students with the support they need to
address their mental health
concerns it's crucial that schools
promote awar
awareness and education around mental
health helping to reduce stigma and
encourage open
conversation way at
ala in 2011 confirms that a broader
cooperation among schools parents health
institutions and organizations also play
a sign efficient role into supporting
team's mental health having a strong
support system can make a lot of
difference parents should strive to
create an open and
nonjudgmental space guidance for this
they should not have support just from
above mentions
institutions but also their child's
friends help
matter friends can be understanding
empathetic and offer a listening
year as Alysia at l in
2012 suggests that formal and informal
interactions help for a better recovery
process sometimes just letting someone
know that they're not alone can make
[Music]
aous
impact encouraging self-care practices
is another essential aspect of the in
mental health teens should be encouraged
to
prioritize their wellbeing by engaging
in active activities that promote
relaxion and stress
reduction regular exercise practicing
mindfulness or meditation engaging in
hobbies and maintaining a healthy
lifestyle can all contribute to a
positive heal mental
health it's so important to address the
union challenges that teams face in our
digital
age the constant presence of social
media can amp amplify feelings of
compression self-d and
inity resulting in a serious mental
health
problem
therefore increaing healthy social media
habits and promoting digital well-being
can help teens maintain a healthier
relationship with
technology to conclude it's essential
for teens to know that it's okay to ask
for help seeking support from trained
professionals such as therapist or
conss can provide valuable guidance and
tools for managing mental health
challenges additionally people in charge
of Health institutions should make
available help lines and online
resources to provide mental care and
psychological
consultancy remember everyone's journey
is different and it's important to
prioritize your well-being and seek
support when needed thank you so much
for joining us on this episode of
te of high school
memories it's been an incredible journey
and we are so glad you came along for
the
ride until next time take
[Music]
care